the third situation was in Russia I
didn't realize there was a commotion
going on in the corridor one of my
students was being beaten up because
another drunk Russian For the Rest full
of rings
and not sort of dress rings but the ring
sort of rings that are meant to
leave you without recognization of your
face afterwards
they were fighting outside and didn't
realize and
our apartment door burst open
and there was this really quite stocky
short chap who was drunk also but he
could he could speak English enough
English
to for me to understand
I stood roughly about a meter and a half
from him
so ma was very important and I made this
and I said hey
what's wrong
and he just said you're not coming past
me
and I didn't realize at the time that
there was a fight going on in the room
and I said what do you mean I'm not
coming past you I don't need to come
past you
and I was very calm
and I said why are you in this room
and he did explain that but what he said
was he was a champion of all Russia
boxer he was a boxing champion you know
this means he was
like perhaps Olympic level or
but he was a champion of all Russia so
who would want to fight him because I've
always believed that boxer
is about the worst person you want to
take on
so I said
so if you're
the best
boxer or your one of the top boxers in
Russia
why are you standing in front of an old
man
threatening to hurt me
you'll easily beat me so why why are you
doing this you should be ashamed of
yourself
and I taught him for a few minutes
telling him that
he should respect his art and he should
respect that he's a great boxer and he
shouldn't be wasting his time
threatening an old man
and I said to him one punch and I'm
finished so why are you doing this
he walked away
allowed me to go into the
corridor
someone had taken one of the fighter
with all the Rings
was um
still fighting and he picked up my
Balkan
because the bakkens were lying there
because it was our apartment and our
corridor
it wasn't a corridor walk through it was
a corridor from bedroom to bedroom and
from to the lounge
I am held the Balkan but on the sword
end and I'll always remember
and he said
in broken English again it's mine
and I said no it's mine and and I don't
know why but I found a power
that they only talk about in rare
occasions where your strength becomes
phenomenal
I held the Balkan
and he could not move as if the can was
fixed in cement
however hard he tried I stood there
the boxer talked him into letting it go
and they went off outside
I went out on the balcony
and I didn't smoke
but I've had time somebody offered me a
cigarette and the balcony of our one and
I smoked and I was shaking
but that is the only point where I shook
up until that point I was very very calm
but once I thought about the situation
I trembled and um
really did make me wonder what I just
experienced and being in another country
is always the worst feeling because you
don't know how you're going to end up
alive dead
they're not a strange Hospital
so there's lots of factors to one's life
I know this may seem to be a long film
but I've never gone through it in detail
before
one of the things that I was sad about
was in that room where the pops were
burst in
was too highly
well one was a high down grade and one
was
I made him dang right that's all I'd
like to say and I won't say their names
but I suddenly realized that I was there
on my own because they weren't there I
don't remember looking round
but after the boxer had gone into the
corridor and before I went in there
they were hiding behind the sofa
they'd squat it down behind the sofa
so even being downgrades of what I call
very high quality
they couldn't help me or they didn't
help me
I don't regret it and I don't hold them
responsible I'm just saying this is how
people react in a real situation
they couldn't handle the real situation
I didn't know I could could or couldn't
handle bit until after the event as I
say I was handed a cigarette I smoked
the cigarette I was shaking like a leaf
at least two or three hours afterwards
my adrenaline was going up and down
confusing me not knowing
but looking down they'd also the
Russians had all sat at the table
where they were still drinking
but the Box had sobered up
and he kept bowing saying I'm sorry
Scentsy I'm sorry
and I just looked over the balcony and
said it's too late now you've disgraced
yourself you cannot take that back
I mean who am I to say that you know to
him but
we should never disgrace ourselves
however good we are or we'll never know
how good we are we must never think that
we're better than we are
as I said when I was young
of course
we're Above All That we're
indestructible
but looking back on life now I've had
some lucky escapes